the next speaker is has traveled a long
way today so we should thank him for
coming all the way from sheffield yeah
which is probably the longest travel
visitor today i would imagine philip
coventry who is the project and ops
manager
for community energy england phillip
over to you
well hello everybody thank you very much
for having me it's lovely to be here and
it's a real pleasure to see so many
people interested in local and community
energy that's a very nice thing kind of
sitting where we do in sheffield um it's
nice to come down and have this kind of
experience of seeing all
of these people in the one particular
area which i haven't ever been to before
so yes it's lovely to be here thank you
so i am going to start by introducing
you to us because i imagine many of you
won't know who community energy england
is
so our
vision is and what we want to see happen
is a thriving community energy sector
integrated into and truly powering a
fair zero carbon energy system that's
our big scale vision that's what we
think is possible
um but we understand it's a it's a it's
a large kind of view of the future
what we do is we focus on active
organizations in the sector those range
from those getting started so that may
be many of you here today to those that
are well established in size technical
capability and breadth of activity
we help those organizations implement
new projects innovate improve and grow
we do this primarily with two objectives
one of which is helping those
organizations connect with each other we
run events that kind of thing to help
because obviously if you're getting
started in one small sort of part of the
country you you don't know what has been
going on elsewhere
and then objective two is to engage with
policy makers the government and we meet
with mps and uh we lobby for more
supportive policy to help the sector
grow uh that's a key one
so
since our founding in 2014 we've grown
to membership of over 270 and they're
throughout england and we have a range
of partners
and we take a collaborative approach
because we're very small the sector is
largely voluntary so we have to work
hard to try and make connections and
engage other stakeholders in the sector
to try and achieve more than we might
otherwise be able to so there's a little
graphic of all our partners up there and
and that's an important part of our
approach
so what i'm going to do today is try and
introduce and
explain a bit about community energy
help you understand the breadth of the
sector across the country and give you
this give you a view of what's happening
across england and hopefully to give you
some information about those projects
but also encourage you to
get involved yourselves
so
we might need to start with a definition
of community energy so community energy
brings people together to take
democratic climate action by
understanding generating owning using
and saving energy this has various
dimensions community energy provides
clear accountability participatory
governance within the energy system
which is empowering transparent and
equitable it accelerates the transition
to a zero carbon energy system while
increasing community resilience and it
includes communities that otherwise may
be excluded from the energy system
although that's already a lot it is more
than this building a zero carbon energy
system is a social issue that requires a
just transition hopefully some of you
will be familiar with that term
community energy organizations already
at the forefront of innovation within
the energy system they've initiated
behavior change in their communities
they've accelerated the decentralization
of the energy system and they've reduced
carbon emissions all while upskilling
communities across the uk and creating
jobs
community energy does all of this by
building the consent trust and active
participation needed to ensure a rapid
and just energy transition
so where is the community energy sector
how are we doing in 2020
community energy well sorry to buy i
should say 20 obviously 2021 2020 is the
figures that we have from from last year
we do an annual survey to gather this
information so
as you know community energy is
disparate it's geographically spread
it's all over all over the country in
towns villages and cities
um so that means it can be quite hard to
comprehend the impact and the scale of
the sector so this graphic gives some of
our statistics that we gathered in 2020
um to give you a kind of help you get
your head around what community energy
is doing
and i hope that's encouraging to see
when you're kind of from this part of
suffolk you can see what the sector is
doing all over the country when we add
it all together
the impact is significant
but it is the combination of the impacts
that you can see on the screen so it's
not just generating electricity
it's a lot more that goes into the
sector and what the sector achieves and
produces
that's also why the sector has such huge
potential and why again i encourage you
all to get involved
so
also i think it's important to consider
the challenge that we're facing it's
been mentioned already and there's some
other introductions
and obviously i think community energy
is great full stop and have no question
mark about it but others may not be so
sure
so i think it is important to think
about
why community energy is relevant and
important
ultimately that goes back to the
challenges that we're facing and the
ways that community energy can help us
respond
so hopefully most of you will be
familiar with the realities of climate
change the concept of net zero that kind
of language and terminology
climate change is widespread rapid and
intensifying according to the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
and the challenge is for every single
one of us
there's no single plan or solution to
such a complex problem
the uk does have strong climate change
legislation you can see the purple
blocks on the screen are the carbon
budgets which come from the uk climate
act
so
we've already taken steps to introduce
some
governmental change
but
the
so sorry excuse me
um
getting lost um and as well as the the
legislation that we have uh public
awareness of the challenge is increasing
so um the government's own surveys found
that in march 2021 80 of the public said
they were either very concerned or
fairly concerned about climate change 80
is a big number although still 20 left
to who aren't so clear
um as you well hopefully also know the
cop 26 climate change conference in
glasgow is coming up soon so that's
another big focus
the heat and building strategy and the
net zero strategy were published by the
government on tuesday so also important
legislation
well not legislation important documents
from the government
but it will take more than this kind of
high level legislation to ensure that we
tackle the problem of climate change
collectively the many changes we'll need
to make will involve a combination of
new technologies processes and human
behavior
the graphic on the screen illustrates
various pathways that have been set out
by national grid this year pathways to
net zero
and the detail of what's written in each
one isn't important but it's just an
illustration that there's no right way
to get to net zero and to tackle climate
change
millions of decisions will need to be
made over the coming decades by global
and uk politicians at the high level all
the way down to individual people and
their communities and each one of you in
here at the lowest levels
again from national grid this is a
graphic which is actually quite a simple
one relative to the full complexity of
the energy system but i just wanted to
put it up there to illustrate the many
interconnected elements that go up to
make our energy system
it's naturally quite difficult for most
people to get their heads around and
something so complicated even i um
having worked in the industry for a
little while now couldn't
explain every single part of the energy
and electricity systems
so
when you start from that level of
complexity it's then even harder to get
your head around the changes of
technology digitization energy
distribution and use how we heat our
buildings all of which will be part of
getting us to net zero
so
many of us very rarely think about the
energy system the lights come on when we
flick the switch
hot water comes out of the tap
power cuts thankfully for most of us are
very rare
however in march 2021 40 of the public
were either very worried or fairly
worried about paying for their energy
bills
obviously we have also recently had
extreme price spikes in the electricity
market multiple suppliers going bust
there's been criticism of the way the
energy market regulation interacts with
the generation of electricity and heat
in this country
all while large numbers of people are
already in fuel poverty and unsure
whether they can afford to heat their
homes adequately
so this kind of question that's on the
screen now takes us beyond just
accepting the decisions that are made
about the energy system by the
government and network operators both in
terms of infrastructure and how we get
to net zero
i want to point to the costs and
opportunities within the transition to
net zero and the future energy system we
create as a country
over the course of the next few years
our energy system needs to transform
into a smarter more flexible and
responsive ultra-low carbon energy
system
this transformation is necessary for the
uk to meet its commitment to achieve net
zero greenhouse gas emissions no later
than 2050.
to start understanding why communities
and people are important for tackling
climate change which is the key topic
today
we need to consider how people and their
behavior are both involved in and will
be affected by the energy system
the graphic on the screen is from the
center for sustainable energy they've
done some good work on how people will
be affected
and can be included in the future energy
system
the way that people use energy and
engage with technology their financial
implications of changes to the energy
system both the costs and the benefits
involved the personal and social
dimensions to how we engage with energy
people's
readiness to engage and harness new
technology as well as buy it and how our
homes and our local areas are involved
and affected by energy so these lenders
are relevant to all of us i'm sure every
one of you here can understand that but
they have additional importance when we
consider the most vulnerable in society
and how they'll be affected by and
involved in the energy system and
potentially excluded from or left behind
by the transition
six parliamentary select committees
recently commissioned the uk climate
assembly which was an attempt to
understand public preferences on how the
uk should tackle climate change because
of the impact all of the many decisions
involved will have on people's lives
the assembly brought together people
from all walks of life to learn about
climate change and discuss what the uk
does to meet its net zero targets and
how it does it
in the final report the assembly
highlighted key themes that recurred
throughout their discussions
helping people understand the scale of
the challenge and what changes in action
are necessary
ensuring fairness across multiple
dimensions and enabling people and
communities to make decisions and be
involved in decisions
this shows the appetite in society for
transparency fairness and again relevant
to today action at the local level and
driven by individual people
so now i'm going to focus on what
communities and people can do and why
they're an essential part of achieving
net zero
so the importance of energy communities
community energy organizations have led
the way by developing models for
deploying and supplying energy which
have local people at their heart
community energy has the potential to
deliver powerful solutions that focus on
a better deal for the people that use
and pay for energy
so why is why is community energy
important
it's a trusted local partner
community energy builds trust with
consumers through sustained engagement
and a genuine in-depth understanding of
a place its residents and businesses
this means community energy can reach
those that others cannot
allowing it to build relationships with
the most vulnerable in society
energy democracy
through its democratic governance
structures and cooperative models and
the investment and engagement practices
community energy brings more people into
the energy transition including those
that may not have been engaged
considered and listened to before
empowerment
the direct nature of the relationship
between community energy projects and
the beneficiaries of those projects
creates a strong sense of empowerment
that permeates into other areas of
people's lives this is particularly
important given the scale of the climate
change challenge and the impact of
individual actions that's difficult to
comprehend
new investment
community energy organizations ability
to raise finance locally
through community shares bond offers and
crowdfunding opens up new investment
that otherwise would not be available
and again brings new people into the
energy transition
a local solution to global problems
community energy offers a practical
means for people to take action that
contributes to tackling climate change
but also brings many local benefits some
of which i'll expand on later
and recycling economic benefits
community ownership of businesses and
assets is a bigger part of the economy
than energy and there are many
organizations like cooperative uk out
there seeking to help this broader
sector to grow but community ownership
of local energy projects ensures that
the income generated by those projects
can be invested back into communities
themselves to create enduring positive
impacts
community energy can also create local
jobs stimulate the development of local
markets and
target investment towards local supply
chains
and even our politicians agree with this
we've had some warm words in the past
from politicians some of those are on
the screen
they've acknowledged the importance of
engaging people and communities
in the transition to net zero
community energy was referenced in the
recent net zero strategy that was
published this week
but there is only unfortunately limited
evidence of the present government
taking the need for communities to be
engaged and involved sufficiently
seriously
both in terms of reducing uk emissions
and adapting to the impacts of climate
change
so
it will take again i've said this before
it will take more just than just
legislation to ensure that we can tackle
the problem of climate change
climate change will involve change will
involve a combination of new
technologies processes and human
behavior the statistic on the screen
comes from the climate change committee
which is again part of the uk climate
change act
we can't just use large-scale
interventions to get where we need to
get to decarbonization so far has
focused on how energy is generated and
supplied to homes and businesses and
already i'm the first speak the main
speaker but i'm not even the first
person to say that the changes that have
happened so far are largely invisible to
most people
to reach net zero there needs to be much
more direct changes to people's behavior
and choices
while people must be engaged there is a
risk that the changes to the energy
system leave vulnerable people behind
and create negative social impacts
in this case public reaction to these
kind of injustices will undermine
political will to sustain the transition
affecting the momentum we need to
harness and increase to get to net zero
so supporting community energy community
energy has a long track record of
delivering community owned renewable
energy generation often on uncommercial
sites
energy efficiency and fuel poverty work
and increasingly
large-scale innovation projects embedded
in communities
community energy offers a deep reach and
a sustained connection with people often
based on local knowledge and
face-to-face interaction this enables a
deep understanding of local people and
of places which supported by a
reputation for independence can result
in deeper relationships with energy
consumers and much higher levels of
trust than other organizations involved
in the energy system
community energy has been around for
well over a decade but the last two
years have changed many people's
understanding of their local communities
and built a range of new connections
we've also seen new dimensions to public
consent trust and fairness during the
pandemic
recognizing the immense suffering that
has been involved the pandemic has shown
how resilient and effective community
and community action can be
communities gathering momentum from the
ground level to respond to climate
change can drive the progress we need to
see and influence action by governments
businesses and others in society the
commitment and pride of communities can
be part of the solution and ensure the
process of decarbonisation is equitable
and empowering for all
community energy organizations are
already deeply embedded in their
communities
the people that are involved and drive
the project the purpose of the
organizations written into their
constitutions and defined by their their
organizational structures
and their place within broader community
networks
many community energy organizations
distribute surplus income from
generating renewable energy directly
back to their local communities
several were able to rapidly
redistribute funding to covid relief
efforts
releasing over 200 000 pounds
particularly quickly in 2020 as the
pandemic got started
other community energy organizations are
active in fuel poverty advisory services
and as the pandemic and the lockdowns
took hold um they were able to integrate
these with other covid initiatives and
assist with extra support provided
during the pandemic all of this was
possible because of the strong networks
and collaborations that are a core
characteristic of community energy
we talk a lot about co-benefits when we
talk about community energy but this is
because the track record of community
energy in the sector shows what can be
achieved when local people come together
to take action
some highlights for you
consistently climate community energy
leverages tens of millions of pounds a
year in community investment
community energy consistently pays out
millions of pounds a year to local
charities and projects within their
communities
for example southeast london community
energy calculated that for every one
pound invested in their energy
efficiency work there was a 24 pounds
social return on investment and which is
a bit of jargon but it will mean
something to some people particularly
local authorities
including a six pound financial saving
to householders over two years mostly in
savings on energy bills
by a conservative sorry that's six
pounds per pound rather than six pounds
um total
by a conservative calculation using
treasury green book values again a bit
of jargon but that will again mean
something to people involved a report
for devon community and devon county
council sorry calculated that they would
generate almost 16 million pounds of
additional local benefit by buying their
energy from local community energy
projects rather than procuring it
commercially as is the case
and devon county council have set up a
model to do this now and it's underway
community wind farms this is a report
from scotland they pay on average 34
times more community benefit than is the
industry standard for commercial wind
farms
while commercial renewable energy and
energy efficiency providers are of
course necessary to get us to net zero
community energy is unique in
democratizing energy by enabling local
people to take on a more proactive role
in the energy system transition and
derive further
social economic and environmental
benefits for their communities via
business models that have people at
their core
the future of energy is local
it's a phrase something that we might
like to say but what does it mean
as the drive to reach net zero gathers
pace and the energy transition becomes
both more complex and more urgent it's
at the local level that the needs and
characteristics of the of people and
their communities can be understood it's
at the local level that planning must
happen for a net zero transition that is
effective rapid fair and inclusive
it's at the local level that people can
really be encouraged supported and
enabled to change behavior and make
choices that will help the energy
transition
community energy organizations are
already active at this local level they
build extensive networks in their
communities and with a range of
different types of people they're
trusted by vulnerable people and have a
reputation for independence
they
they by being involved in projects they
can avoid wasted effort and
inappropriate infrastructure that
doesn't meet the needs of local people
they're effective at delivering
information and advice to individuals
particularly those that are hard to
reach
and their their function and operations
give people a tangible stake in the
energy system
so what is working now in community
energy by now you're probably wondering
this
um the backbone of community energy
remains putting solar on rooftops this
is happening all over the country with a
variety of different models sometimes
it's independent community energy
organizations doing it themselves
sometimes they're they use umbrella or
support organizations like solar for
schools share energy or energy for all
this is a great first step and something
i certainly encourage many of you who
don't know how to get started with
energy in your communities to look at
there are also numerous organizations
around the country providing fuel
poverty and energy advice services which
is a key one and is often for those of
you who here from local authorities
can really help to meet the the
objectives and
requirements of local authorities um the
services like this are often provided
often funded by the surplus income from
generating renewable electricity
there is much more to the sector though
and as well as new and innovative
business models which are emerging
so i'll start with energy efficiency
i've got a few examples so people
powered retrofit is a not-for-profit
service for householders in greater
manchester
offering clear independent advice to
support and help people plan procure and
deliver home retrofits retrofit is when
you make changes to a house or a
building to increase its energy
efficiency
um people-powered retrofit is trying to
tackle the key barriers that a lot of
homeowners face in commissioning work
such as lack of appropriate contractors
concerns about the quality of the work
that we carried out and a lack of local
markets for this kind of energy
efficiency work
so they're halfway to raising 550 000
pounds in a community share offer
um just showing that the kind of the the
demand for that kind of service but also
um hopefully you can see that the the
kind of work that they do is is not
geographically specific it's something
that is important everywhere this
country needs retrofit everywhere
another organization doing this kind of
work is the cold homes energy efficiency
survey experts
that's quite a mouthful but those of you
who are quick might have spotted that
that's the cheese project
they're bristol-based not-for-profit
community interest company that aims to
reduce domestic energy losses at low
cost they do energy efficiency surveys
and they start 135 pounds
which again hopefully you can see is
fairly low cost and are free to people
in poor housing conditions and in fuel
poverty and that kind of work to help
engage those who are less able to pay
those more vulnerable in society as a
key hallmark of community energy
the cheese project is in the process of
expanding their project to create a
uk-wide social franchise
and again that's the kind of thing that
we need in the sector so that people who
are here um for example if you haven't
got involved in energy efficiency work
you can take up that kind of franchise
model and get it going in your community
um heat
is a significant challenge for the uk
we've got a prevalence of gas boilers
many rural areas are off the gas grid
and reliant on heating oil
heat has been in in the news recently
with heat pumps and things so um you're
probably all aware of it a little bit um
the example that i've got on the screen
and i was just going to mention is
actually going to be covered a little
bit in in the next talk so i won't go
into it hugely but brighton and hove
energy services cooperative down
surprisingly in brighton
have been working on how to move a rural
village in sussex over from heating oil
onto renewable energy heating system
integrating solar pv heat pumps and
improved energy efficiency and the the
key thing that i want to mention here is
that it's financed through a community
community share office said the
community
the community engineer organization gets
the investment and then the residents
pay monthly for the heat rather than
paying upfront for the installations
which is a barrier for many
um and our energy generation and
flexibility again are a key backbone of
the sector so an example here is riding
sunbeams and kakamir community solar
they're down in sussex again they're
building the first community owned small
ground solar farm which will be
connected directly into the rail
network's power supply
the first in a model that obviously has
nationwide potential given that railways
are almost everywhere
because it's community owned the surplus
funds from generating the electricity
will flow directly back to the community
and network rail gets cheaper green
electricity so it's a win-win win wins
or win win win win win we can kind of
add lots of wins onto that again is a
hallmark of the sector with all the
co-benefits that we we kind of champion
community energy south again who you're
going to be hearing from later are
expanding their successful pathway
partnerships with local authorities that
stimulate community energy activity in
particular areas so again if you're from
a local authority i encourage you to
stay to hear ollie later
bath and west community energy
they used in a previous project they use
electricity substation data to equip
people in a community with the
information that they need to reduce
their energy demand or shift in time for
example turning the washing machine on
at a different time of day i mentioned
this because
the
the the time at which we use energy
affect how much pressure is placed on
the local electricity grid and this kind
of behavior change will be an important
part of minimizing the cost involved in
the energy transition and again
community energy involved on the ground
with local people is perfectly placed to
deliver that kind of information and
equip people to change their behavior
and
a whole systems approach
so this is the future of the energy
system it's a terminology which will
become increasingly prominent if you're
involved in the energy sector
it's
an approach which seeks to actively
engage with the fact that energy use and
generation are interconnected with each
other and with a wide range of other
aspects of infrastructure including
electricity and heat but also transport
buildings for example as well as
multiple actors such as local
authorities utility companies and
housing developers in addition
recognizing the centrality of people's
behavior and the characteristics and
needs of individuals in their
communities along with the context of
the distribution and transmission
networks and their constraints and needs
overarching all of this is the need for
rapid decarbonisation so that i know
that is quite a mouthful but it's quite
complex and it's hard to get your head
around but i'm happy to talk about whole
systems afterwards
anyway to illustrate what that means in
practice at the moment
an example is in devon the tot nest
renewable energy society is working with
a housing developer to integrate solar
pv
so sorry that solar solar panels and
roofs
electric vehicle charging stations and a
hot water system on a micro grid within
the housing development which is a small
scale electricity network separated from
but connected to the main electricity
grid they're using again this energy as
a service approach so that residents pay
for the use of the the heat or hot water
in this case rather than the
installation of the infrastructure
another example is charge my street
which has become the second largest ev
charging network operator in cumbria i
know that's a long way from here they've
got a community-owned model which is
aiming to install charges where
communities themselves need them to be
located
they're working also on more complex
projects where ev charging is one
element alongside generation and supply
of electricity to buildings within the
context of constraints on the
electricity network
now what is the future of community
energy where is the sector going our
energy energy system is changing
increased local generation and storage
electrification of heating and transport
systems and the rise of flexibility
services to help balance the grid in
real time are all happening now and
they'll shape the future of energy
infrastructure and the way it meets our
needs and how we interact with it
if we're to develop a truly innovative
and effective future energy system
people whether that's community groups
houses or businesses must be put at the
heart of the energy system
last year we published our 2030 vision
which was based on a detailed
consultation process with community
energy practitioners and project
projections from a report by wpi
economics about what the sector can
achieve the vision sets out our
understanding of the dimensions of a
cohesive zero carbon energy system with
empowered communities at the center and
you can access that it's free on our
website graphics like this and the
previous slides are all part of it um so
i encourage you to use that to help
in your communities
as well as driving the transition to
renewable energy increasing energy
efficiency and reducing fuel poverty at
the ground level
community energy organizations around
the country are active partners in
sophisticated innovation projects and
trials
i'm going to give a couple of examples
hopefully to inspire you about what you
might be able to get involved with
so in the midlands chase community
sailor is part of the zero carbon
rougely consortium which is developing
smart local energy system encompassing 7
000 homes 400 commercial premises and
two railway stations using numerous
integrated energy solutions that will be
designed and digitally operated at local
level
as you can see much bigger scale to the
usual work of community energy
historically
another one is project leo in
oxfordshire not as far away
which is a holistic smart grid trial in
which community energy organization low
carbon hub is helping to ensure that
individuals households and organizations
are integrated into the design and
implementation of the smarter
decarbonized energy system so that no
one is left behind in the transition
so those two are pretty big projects and
pretty complex but i hope that again it
inspires you to see what community
energy can achieve when it perseveres
and gains experience and works with a
range of other partners in summary
community energy is a key way of
engaging people to own the net zero
project and is essential to achieving it
the sector has huge potential
with the right support it can grow
significantly and could power over 2
million homes and add almost 2 billion
pounds a year to the economy
um i've hit my 30 minutes so i'll stop
there but um well i'll stop in a second
but
what i wanted to do was just explain a
little bit about what we offer so if
you're just getting started we offer a
range of support for your organization
we don't do
project advice one-to-one project advice
but there's a lot on our website in
terms of uh how you can find out what to
do what works um get inspiration from
other projects um i basically suggest
that if you're starting out in a
community energy organization you join
us it's free when you're just getting
going and then you can access our
community and networks and the resources
that we offer so talk to me afterwards
if you're interested in that and i can
explain a little bit more about what's
on the screen here these are all short
links by the way so um i don't know
whether you can take a photograph of it
but if these slides get sent around
afterwards it will have all these links
that you can kind of type in
and yeah i encourage you to see what's
what's on offer on our website and
basically to connect up with other
organizations because it's great to see
people here coming from um across the
community in a particular area but again
community energies all over the country
and you can connect to and get
inspiration and advice from others
who've been going at it for a lot longer
so i will
finish there thank you very much again
for the opportunity to speak to you
today and i encourage you all to get
involved in and support the sector in
any way that you can
and i look forward to the rest of the
day thank you very much
[Applause]